>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, everyone
and thank you all for coming.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb, Chief of the
African and Middle East Division
and I'm happy to see you all here.
Today's program is
the first this fall
in the ongoing library series
entitled, "Conversations
with African Poets and Writers."
And this particular program is
the twenty-fourth in the series.
In October 2011, the African section
of the African Middle East Division,
in partnership with the Poetry
and Literature Center headed
by Rob Casper, who is represented
today by Anya Creightney
who will be speaking, and in
partnership with the African Society
of the National Summit on
Africa, which was then headed
by Bernadette Paolo and is
now headed by Patricia Bain
who will be speaking, too.
She's the President.
And by Ambassador Pamela
Bridgewater who is here with us,
the Chairman of the Society.
Well, those three organizations
launched a new program here
at the Library of Congress
consisting of conversations
and interviews with established and
emerging poets, short story writers,
novelists, and playwrights of
continental and diasporic Africa.
Four years later, the
series has become well known
and well established, and
has brought to the Library
and to our patrons and
readers, as well as all those
who access the Library's
webcasts around the world,
some of the best writers
from Africa.
From those who are no longer with us
like Chinua Achebe and Ali Mazrui,
to poets like the Poet Laureate of
South Africa, Keorapetse Kgositsile,
to the new generation of
writers like Amadou Kone
from the Cote d'Ivoire,
Nigerian writer Igoni Barrett,
the poet Omekongo Dibinga from the
Democratic Republic of the Congo,
to Tijan Sallah, a Gambian poet.
We brought many, many
people to this series.
Last year we even hosted Lemn
Sissay who became the new Chancellor
of the University of Manchester.
And today we have Shenaz Patel
who is the first Mauritian
writer in the series.
She's here thanks to the
International Writers' Program
at the University of Iowa
and the Bureau of Education
and Cultural Affairs of
the Department of State.
I thank you all for bringing
such a wonderful writer to us.
And before we start the program,
I would like to introduce
the President
of our partner organization,
The Africa Society
of the National Summit on Africa,
Patricia Bain who will make
some remarks, after which,
Anya Creightney, who is representing
the Poetry and Literature Center,
will introduce the speaker.
Eve Ferguson, the Africa
Reference Librarian,
will then conduct the conversations.
So without further ado, Patricia.
Thank you.
>> Patricia Bain: Welcome
to Conversations
with African Poets and Writers.
Good afternoon.
My name is Patricia Bain.
I'm the President of the Africa
Society here, as Dr. Deeb said,
with my Chairman, Ambassador
Pamela Bridgewater
and Miss Sarah Caruso
right in the back of her.
Thank you Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Dr. [Inaudible] who is not here,
everybody associated with
the Library of Congress.
For this iteration over
African Poets and Writers I want
to especially thank you, Mary-Jane,
for being an extraordinary
partner in the series.
This is the twenty-fourth.
It's very exciting.
The African's Society's
partnership with the African section
of the Africa and Middle
Eastern Division and the Poetry
and Literature Center of
the Library of Congress
in our view is the perfect marriage
because we both provide a platform
for African literary
figures accessible
to everyone throughout the world
who would not have the privilege
of meeting them but for this forum.
And today we have the pleasure
of an exceptional author,
our first from Mauritius,
Miss Shenaz Patel
who is really also a
playwright, a journalist,
social and culture issues
for Modern Advocate.
You do a lot, Miss Patel.
You're an impressive literary and
culture ambassador from Mauritius.
And having you with us today
makes us cognizant of the myriad
of languages and cultures that
are spoken in the 55 countries
of the African continent.
And the fact that the progress
of African writers is really felt
in countries all over the world.
With you and with all our
previous guests we learn more
about different African
countries, the different voices,
and we grow from what we
learn, as does our audience
and so we're very pleased to
have you [inaudible] today.
And now I will call on Anya.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Anya Creightney: Hi,
everyone, and welcome.
Thank you, Patricia, and thanks
to both the Africa Society,
and the National Summit
on Africa, and the Africa
and Middle Eastern Division
here at the Library of Congress.
My name is Anya Creightney and I'm
the Program Specialist of the Poetry
and Literature Center
here at the Library.
I'm also a proud partner
in this series representing
and celebrating literature from
across the African continent.
I'm thrilled and delighted
to welcome the International
Writers' Program at the University
of Iowa back to the Library of
Congress, and especially pleased
to welcome writer Shenaz
Patel to the Conversations
with African Poets
and Writers series.
The International Writers'
Program is a unique conduit
by connecting established
writers from around the globe
to other cultures via reading tours,
classroom talks, and
public lectures.
Since 1967 over 1400 writers from
more than 190 countries have been
in residence at the
University of Iowa.
Writer Shenaz Patel is one of
these outstanding residents.
A fiction writer and a
playwright hailing from Mauritius,
as has been mentioned, Ms. Patel has
written four novels, numerous plays
and short stories in both
French and Mauritian Creole.
She is best known for
her 2005 novel,
excuse my French, "Le
Silence des Chagos."
It's close as I can get.
[Laughs]. And as a working
journalist, she writes about social
and cultural issues, much
like Patricia has mentioned.
And she's often seeking to
unearth the unsaid and the untold.
So I know we are all excited
to hear from her today.
Let me tell you just a word about
the Poetry and Literature Center.
We are the home of the Poet
Laureate Consultant in Poetry.
This year it's Juan Felipe
Herrera in his second term.
And we put on 30 to 40 programs
just like this one a year.
To find out more about our series
and other programs of the Library
of Congress you can visit us at
www.loc.gov/poetry or to find
out more about the
Conversations with African Poets
and Writers series that Mary-Jane
Deeb was listing the various
writers, please visit
www.loc.gov/rr/amed.
And certainly last,
but not least I want
to thank our presenting partners
The Bureau of Educational
and Cultural Affairs at the
U.S. Department of State
and the Penn Faulkner Foundation.
Now let me turn it over to
Shenaz for a reading followed
by a conversation with Eve.
Please.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Shenaz Patel: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm very happy and honored
to be with you here today.
It's a very special
occasion for me and I'd
like to thank particularly the IWP
for bringing me here to Washington,
first to Iowa City where we've been
spending two months-and-a-half now
with 36 different writers from 30
different countries and it has been
such an enlightening and
great experience to be able
to share the literature of
other countries and also share
on a human point of view with so
many writers which I especially want
to thank because they have brought a
lot to my understanding of the world
and my understanding of people.
And all that is going to come
through in the future
writing so thank you so much.
I would like to read
today from the novel,
[inaudible] "Le Silence des
Chagos," which is a novel
which was published a few
years ago which is very,
very special to my heart.
For me it's not just a
novel, it's a life story.
It's based on a true
and tragic story.
It recounts what happened to a
population called the Chagossians.
They lived on islands, an
archipelago, the archipelago
of Chagos which initially belonged
to the territory of Mauritius.
Mauritisu, as you know,
is a small island state
in the middle of the Indian Ocean.
And we were formerly a British
colony from 1810 to 1968
when we gained our independence.
And when Mauritius asked
for its independence
in the 1960's the British
said, "Okay.
We're going to give you independence
but we're just going to keep
that part of your territory,
the Chagos archipelago."
And there was a deal between
the British and the Americans
who wanted this particular place
and the main island that archipelago
which is called Diego Garcia, they
wanted to establish a military base
on this island because it was
ideally situated in the middle
of the Indian Ocean to be able
to control the whole
of the Middle East.
And it must be known that
most of the bombings that went
on these last years on
Afghanistan and Iraq killing
from the island of Diego Garcia.
So the United States said that
these islands are very important
to maintain the security
of the "free" world.
But what is not really known is that
this freedom happened at the expense
of the freedom of a population, the
Chagossians who were living there
and who were disposed of
in terrible conditions.
The British said to
the American that,
first that there was no
[inaudible] on these islands.
Then they had to get rid,
in a way, of these people
and this happened in
two different phases.
The first one, they tried to get
the people away by different means.
They closed the hospital.
They didn't send what we needed
for everyday life at first
and they tried to get
them to go to Mauritius.
And when they wanted to take the
boat back to go back to the islands,
they were told that
the islands were closed
and that they weren't going back.
And then the second phase in
the beginning of the, 1972,
the Americans were getting
impatient so they just sent a boat.
The people were given half an hour
to collect their things and get
on the boat and go away without
being told what was happening
to them, where they
were being taken.
And they were thrown in Mauritius,
totally helpless and
without anything.
And these people have been fighting
for years for the recognition
of the harm that has
been done to them.
Mauritius has been
fighting also as a state
to claim sovereignty
on that [inaudible].
And three weeks back
our Prime Minister was
at the National Assembly of
the United Nations in New York
to reaffirm our claim on these
islands and this is a story
that struck me, not for its
geopolitical and historical context,
but for the people
who were concerned.
And I met some of these people.
They confided their story to me and
I really wanted to get it across,
the story of how you feel
when you're confronted to this
in your life, how you live
through that, if you can,
because a lot of Chagossians
didn't go through it.
A lot of them committed
suicide and it was very,
very hard for their population.
And so I met some of them and
they confided their story to me.
And this book is a way of
trying to get their story
across because they
didn't have a voice
at that time to tell
their own story.
So I'm just going to read an extract
from "Le Silence des Chagos."
"Charlesia was starting to be
fed up with all those Mauritians
who aimed to hold her back.
At the hospital the doctor had
been saying for a long time now
that her husband was completely
recovered and he could leave.
It was obvious that he was, and
for that matter, she'd been sure
that she could have treated
him at home in Diego Garcia.
A few days of [inaudible]
infusions to lower tension
and fresh coconut milk to cleanse
the symptoms would have disappeared.
But the nurse over there
was a scare monger.
He has to go to Mauritius.
We can't take care
of him anymore here.
He has to seek treatment
in Mauritius.
That's what they wouldn't
stop saying to Charlesia.
Even the administrator
encouraged her to leave.
'Go. You have to go.
He'd be better cared for in
Mauritius and it will do you good.
You've worked hard anyway.
It's vacation season.
Bring the kids.
Have a good time.
Stop worrying.'
She finally let them
convince her and they left
on the next voyage of
the Mauritius boat.
They disembarked there at the
end of that queue which led
to the dust clotted
noise of Port Louis,
the capital city of
Mauritius Island.
More than a month had passed since.
Her husband was fully recovered and
it was well past time to return.
They'd been imposing for too long
on these people with
their six children.
It will be soon that
their welcome turned
to vinegar, she could feel it.
They had a funny way of
living here, always in a rush,
constantly required to stuff
themselves inside the claustrophobic
hub cities.
The children were getting restless.
They needed space, their space.
This time the people
at the [inaudible] office
would have to reply to her.
She'd come there twice
already asking
when the next boat
would depart for Chagos.
She could see herself
[inaudible], turning her back
to the great port surrounded by
those eyesore high mountains,
sea filling her lungs, a brief,
calm journey to the north
and then one morning
in the slanted light
of dawn there was a [inaudible]
sprinkled over the water
like a spray of gentle
prayers, whispered, 'Granted.'
Charlesia pulls the flower
embroidered handkerchief
from her blouse [inaudible].
She enters the office.
A few ceiling fans struggle to turn
their blades, creaking and wheezing
under a layer of dust
and [inaudible].
Seven men, shirt sleeves rolled up,
are seating behind green formica
desks, [inaudible] in their teacups.
Chalesia goes up to the person
standing closest to the door.
He raises his head,
tosses her a brief glance.
'My, look who's here.'
A sharp laugh lifts
up through the room.
Charlesia holds her ground.
[Foreign language spoken].
She's not asking them for sorcery.
She simply wants to know
when the next boat leaves
for Chagos, her home.
The fans creak a little louder.
[Foreign language spoken],
go on tell her.
The voice comes from the back
of the room between two piles
of folders another man looks at her
with something evasive in his eyes
but his voice is firm,
'She has to be told.'
An immense silence descends
over [inaudible] head.
It lands suddenly on her
chest which contracts
and she's powerless to control it.
Another voice rises up beside
her, 'Then tell her yourself.'
The man hesitates, he
fidgets with his pen,
twirling it between
his thick fingers,
his nails almost perfect
squares, 'I'll ask the boss.'
His chair scrapes on the
floor, he give a discreet knock
on the glass door, listens briefly,
then turns the cover handle and goes
in the office, carefully
closing the door behind him.
Charlesia sees him.
He has barely moved forward in the
room, sweat has drawn brown waves
at the back of his beige shirt.
He speaks for a while,
turning around to indicate the
place where she is standing.
Charlesia waits.
The others are [inaudible] work,
[inaudible] away on
their typewriters.
The man raises his hand
again, slips it in his collar,
mechanically he rubs his neck.
Then he waves it in front of him.
He seems to be insisting.
Finally he nods, turns back,
[inaudible] the handle,
opens the door, closes
it again cautiously.
He slowly walks back to
his table, sits down again.
'Well?' asks his colleague.
'Well, he told me to tell her,'
'Hmm. Maybe you should
take her outside.
She looks like a handful,
that one,' he says, laughing.
Charlesia feels like
she's going to lose it.
Are they talking about her?
What is all this gossiping about?
She walks up to the man.
[Foreign language spoken].
He barely lifts his eyes to hers,
yes, he has something to tell her.
Better get on with it.
It's almost noon and he has to hurry
if he doesn't want to get overtaken
by the crowd at the shop where
the stuffed breads are waiting.
'You won't have a return boat.'
He blurted out the sentence,
closing his folder with a force
that made the metal rings
on the side clatter.
Charlesia doesn't move.
She was afraid for a moment
that he had slammed the
folder shut on his fingers.
She already saw his blood streaked
flesh pitch frantically trying
to escape the steel ring
but the restless left hand
couldn't manage to force open.
The sound of the folder
booms in her head.
The clacking rings, the
clattering of the drawer.
He said something to her but
she didn't understand what.
She looks at him to
repeat it but he continues
to shuffle through his belongings.
The others get up around him.
Charlesia doesn't move.
She stares at the man, waiting
for him to repeat his sentence.
'There will be no more
returning ships.
You have to stay here
[foreign language spoken].'
He spoke with a dry
voice, lowered his head,
and arranged his lost
papers in a drawer
that shut carefully with a key.
Charlesia hears the blades from the
fans stirring the air, kicking it up
and sending his words back to
her, '[Foreign language spoken].'
The man approaches her.
Around then the office is empty.
He puts his hand firmly
on her shoulder,
makes her turn to the door.
She's outside.
He disappears.
Over there the sea calls to her
against the current of human waves
that lap toward the exit, step after
step she walks to the farthest point
of the queue where
she stands motionless.
From his sentry box, the
attendant watches her,
hypnotized by that silhouette,
by the red scarf prominent
against the [inaudible] as
backdrop of the glittering sea.
He watches this woman [inaudible]
the sea who appears to be waiting.
Waiting for what?
A boat. An ever absent
boat that tattooed
on the retina of a lookout woman.
She probes the blue span, infinitely
blue, but as much as she tries,
she can't seem to hope
for the curtain.
The sea remains obstinately empty.
There's no boat.
There's no more boat for her.
That's what they have just
told her, yet another one
of their stupid jokes
to pass the time.
No [inaudible].
That doesn't mean anything.
This sentence has no sense.
They'd better [inaudible]
such insanities.
'[Foreign language spoken],'
was that your [inaudible]?
What do they think, this
bunch of simpletons?
That it's a restaurant or something
like their shitty office
of [inaudible]?
Something with opening and
closing hours from nine
to four written up on the doors?
If she threw herself in the water,
would the [inaudible] gunboat
come back to rescue her,
bring her back home on
the other side of the sea?
Charlesia steps up to
the edge of the queue.
The greasy harbor waters
flow heavily
against the concrete parapet.
Over there the horizon
is a sharp, bright line.
The boat has already
gone over it without her.
And she asks herself
wherefrom comes that wave
that falls suddenly
through her whole body?"
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I just wanted to say that
the book is written in French
and that this translation has
been made by Patricia Hartland
who I especially want to
thank for a very beautiful
and loving work she's
done on the translation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eve Ferguson: Okay.
Thank you very much, Shenaz.
That is beautiful.
I think I know how it ends
but I won't give it away.
I did want to mention that today
is rather significant, though,
because yesterday marked
eight years ago that we came
up with the inspiration
somewhat for this series
and that was the celebration
of the fiftieth anniversary
of "Things Fall Apart."
And that was November third, 2008.
I can't believe it's been eight
years already but that has passed,
as has the great author,
Chinua Achebe, so, you know,
we can kind of dedicate
today's program to his memory
as he was the father of the
wave of that African moment.
So that's a moment
of remembering him
and remembering what
happened eight years ago.
And it's a different scenario
because eight years ago we were
the day before election day
and now we're heading into next week
and that's all I'll say about that.
[Laughs].
>> Shenaz Patel: I could say that.
>> Eve Ferguson: We're
supposed to be non-partisan here
so we'll just move on to literature.
So my first question for you
is when did you start writing
and can you talk about
the relationship
between literary writing and
your role as a journalist?
>> Shenaz Patel: To say when I
started writing I'd have to say
when I started reading because
it's so much related to me.
I had the chance to [inaudible]
a family who loved books.
My father would go to the
book island where people
at one time were [inaudible]
selling everything they owned
so people went there to buy
furniture or things like that.
And he went around the
island and came back
with big boxes of old books.
And I didn't quite understand
at first why he did that
and why it was so important.
And very quickly I wanted to be
able to read by myself to be able
to understand what the treasures
in these boxes he brought
back from work.
I became a very eager reader.
I had to read and I still
have to read every day.
I can stay without writing for
some days but not without reading
because I feel like my day will
be so incomplete without reading.
And I think I took in another way
at school I took from the letter A
to letter Z from all the books.
I then I want to point out that
like I also had stories in my head
that I wanted to tell so
that's how the writing came.
But it was a very, very long process
from the beginning of writing
to the fact of publishing
because I think it's very hard.
[Inaudible] telling your
story or [inaudible]
in the books the you write.
You always put a little of
yourself in what you write.
And it took me a very long
time to overcome that kind
of shyness [inaudible] ability as
a fact of showing what I wrote.
And so it wasn't until
I was around 30 I think
that I started publishing.
But writing has always been there
for me as something essential
to my life because I have
the impressions [inaudible],
they're very utopic impressions
that rising could change the world.
And so at first I was high like that
and everybody was asking me what
do you want to do after [inaudible]
when you're a grownup and I
said I want to be a journalist
because I was very struck
by what I saw around me.
I was very ill at ease and
unhappy with a lot of situations
of injustice that I could
see around me and I felt
like I just couldn't do as if
it had nothing to do with me.
And I felt that being a
journalist and writing,
it would perhaps change that.
I have evolved in that
[inaudible] even not totally
and that's why I'm still writing.
And literature is a
different kind of writing
and journalism is very
precise, very [inaudible]
and you don't throughout, a
very precise way of writing.
Literature is my space of freedom
where I can do whatever I want.
I remember a friend telling me one
day, I was kind of going around
and frantically trying to fix
everything that wasn't going right
in the lives of people I love and
he just took me by the shoulders,
he stopped me and he looked
into my eyes and he said,
"You know, you're not God."
I was very disappointed [inaudible].
But then I found out in
literature I could be God.
I could create someone that I
would like to see in my life
and that I wouldn't
perhaps see in my life.
I could create that person.
I could kill him tomorrow
if I was fed up with him.
I could bring him back the day
after if I was missing him.
So literature is my space of
freedom where I can be God
and change the world in a way.
>> Eve Ferguson: Okay.
Excellent.
You know, so Shenaz and I spoke
a little bit briefly before the
program and it came to our
realization we're both journalists
and it's interesting for me to find
out why she started
being a journalist
because it was the
same reason I did.
I was sitting in the middle of
Uganda and Idi Amin took over
and I read things about
Idi Amin and I was like,
"That's not really what I'm seeing."
So I'd change everybody's
opinion by being a journalist
and I gave up on that idea, too.
Didn't pursue the further reading
and then the other thing is
that you are a biblophobic.
I found out this new word.
Biblophobia is the fear of
running out of books to read.
>> Shenaz Patel: Yeah.
That's true.
>> Eve Ferguson: So that's a very
useful word for people like you.
In addition, I just wanted to
make an aside that Chinua Achebe,
that I had asked him why did
he kill my favorite character
in "Things Fall Apart,"
Ikemefuna, and he said,
"I didn't kill Ikemefuna,
Okompo did."
And I said, "But you created
Okompo," and he said, "No,
once I created Okompo
he had his own life."
So I think that when you
say that you get to be God
in your own writing, you know, your
characters become who they want,
who you want them to be
and then they take off
on a life of their own.
>> Shenaz Patel: That's true.
>> Eve Ferguson: So my
next question is who
or what are the major
influences on your work?
>> Shenaz Patel: It's
difficult to say.
There's so many.
I love, it's a strange thing
because I write in French,
my two mother tongues are
French and Creole so I write
in French and originally Creole.
I don't write in English,
I don't know if I should say
unfortunately or anyway not yet.
But I find that [Inaudible] has
been very, very inspiring for me
because in [Inaudible]
I find the vitality
that I don't find in [inaudible].
But he has much more freedom
and [inaudible] with language
in [inaudible] than
French literature.
[Inaudible] nowadays.
And so I've read a lot of
[Inaudible] and I particularly
like authors like [Inaudible]
who could create,
and I was always fascinated
by that person who's
totally not alive at all.
It's ink on a white page and
then suddenly just by the way,
a word here instead of here,
a comma here instead of there,
you create a world and you create
characters who become like persons
and feel like they're alive
and not until you've put
down the book you have impression
that its characters are walking
with you and still be
with you years and years.
And he knows how [inaudible]
creates characters
that you know wouldn't exist
in real life but in the spirits
of the book are really, are alive.
And Salman Rushdie was [inaudible].
"Midnight's Children" for me is
one of these books that really says
so much about the power of
literature to create a world
and to create people that go
beyond what we could experience but
yet tell us so much about who we
are and our place in the world.
>> Eve Ferguson: All right.
My next question for
you, why did you choose
to write fiction as
your creative outlet.
I know you've written short
stories, plays, and news articles,
but also have you delved into
other literary genres like poetry?
>> Shenaz Patel: We
have a discussion,
it's fun that you ask the question
because we have an
ongoing discussion
about that for the past two months.
I've never dared poetry because
I love poetry so much and I felt
like it was higher than me.
But then I've been writing
something since I've been here
and I've been writing in English
which for me is quite strange.
And my friends [inaudible]
tell me that,
"You're writing poems,"
and I said, "No.
I'm not writing poems.
I'm writing text."
But I'm a little bit surprised
about the categorizations we make.
If it's creative non-fiction, or
fiction, or poetry, or novellas,
or short stories, or for
me all these are texts.
And the [inaudible] is not
the genre but the voice.
What I'm looking for in
text is voice and the story.
You write if you have a
story to tell, otherwise,
I mean go play [inaudible].
There are so many stories
around us that want to be told.
And I've tried, I like
particularly the short story
because the short story
for me is like the pebble
that you throw in a pond.
It's very compact.
It goes down very quickly.
But it leaves after it these
ripples on the water which are
like echoes that grow around you.
And a good short story when it's
well written, it's [inaudible].
It's like throwing a
pebble in a pond that gives,
it stays with you for
long afterwards.
People like to think that
writing a novel is more difficult
than writing a short story.
I don't totally agree.
It's another process.
It's a longer process.
But you're not, you can be less
good at some things and try to make
up for it in other aspects.
In a short story you can't.
Either it's well written
and it's good or it's not.
And theater, plays is also a
very interesting field for me
because it's a place where
you're in [inaudible] contact
with the [inaudible] and
that's very important.
When you write a novel, you write it
and then you don't
know where it goes.
You're not in contact
with people who read it
but you can read it afterwards
but it's not the same process.
In the plays, writing is
directly aimed at people
so that's a very interesting
thing also.
I'm also interested in graphic
novels because that's another way.
And in fact, I'm fascinated
by all the different
ways of telling a story.
At the IWP in Iowa City we had
an interaction with some dancers
from their school of dance.
And it was really fascinating to
see how they took some of our texts,
what we got from it and how they
told our story, everybody's,
so how the stories we write
can be told by others.
And we see it and felt by other
people and told different view.
And I think this is [inaudible].
>> Eve Ferguson: Okay.
That's really interesting to me
as a writer because I know also
that it's more difficult to write
a 500 word article than it is
to write a 1500 word article.
So I think the parallel is there
with the news stories also.
>> Shenaz Patel: Yes.
That's one of the first things my
first [inaudible] chief told me
when I started as a [inaudible].
I was nineteen.
And I had been investigating on
something for weeks and weeks
and I came up with so many
information [inaudible] I kind
of said, "Can't I have two
pages of the newspaper?"
And he said, "No.
You won't.
Just one page and you
stick to that."
And I said, "There's so
many things to [inaudible]
that I have to leave aside."
And he said to me, you know, one
day he went to his editor and chief
and gave him this article and said,
"[Inaudible] I didn't have time."
[Inaudible] even more
time to make it short.
>> Eve Ferguson: Okay.
Having been born and
raised in Mauritius,
and what has Mauritian
literature been like historically
and what's happening in
the literary scene now?
>> Shenaz Patel: The actual
literary scene is very active,
very energetic I would say.
There have been, Mauritius
published the first book
in the southern hemisphere
in 18-something, I forget
but in the nineteenth century.
And since then we have had a
very lively literary scene.
There have been different
phases in that.
At one point we had all that
colonial literature [inaudible],
you know, the breeze in the palm
trees and the beautiful young Creole
and the verandas and
things like that.
And [Inaudible] the great French
poet wrote there [inaudible] poem
called [inaudible] for a Creole lady
which was directly inspired
by these [inaudible]
when his parents were
sent him away from Paris
where he was living a very,
how can I say the word?
They didn't like the life he was
living in Paris, the [inaudible]
so they were trying to send him
away to India and on his way
to India the boat stopped
in Mauritius
and then he never went further.
He stayed in Mauritius and
then he went back to France
and he wrote these
poems that are part
of his famous connection
called [Inaudible].
So there has been a lot
of that emotional literature
a few years back.
And then there has been
a second phase where
Mauritian writers felt like
they had to exile themselves
to be able to exist as writers,
that it wouldn't be happening
in Mauritius so they had to go
to France, or England, and to other
countries like that to be recognized
as writers either to
live as writers.
And suddenly we had a lot
of literature that was kind
of looking back at the island like
something dreamed and it over -- .
I can't find the word in English.
>> Eve Ferguson: Romanticized?
>> Shenaz Patel: Yeah.
In a way that's it.
But then we have a generation now
of writers who really know Mauritius
and who talk about Mauritius
in a very different way.
We have writers, a
generation of writers
who are published mostly in France.
I have a friend writer
called [Inaudible].
Her latest novel called
[Inaudible] was in line
for the [inaudible] most prestigious
French prizes a few weeks back,
[foreign language spoken].
And it's interesting to
note that at the same time
as there is the great
vitality of our writers,
we are not read now in our country.
We are read elsewhere
around the world and studied
around the world but
not in our country.
But I think that Mauritians in a
way have a problem with what we tell
and say in our literature.
When my second book came out
it was, it's called "Sensitive"
and it was published in France.
So the news first came
out in the newspapers
that I was having a book published
in France by a great publisher.
And so people came up
to me saying, "Wow.
We are proud.
That's great."
[Inaudible] colony so there's
still that tendency, well,
if it's published over there, it
must be good, it must be great.
And I say, "If it was published
in Mauritius I would have been
writing exactly the same book,"
but never mind.
[Laughs]
Book then the book came out.
People started reading it and
that's where the problem started.
I was approached by a
lady once in a bookstore
when I was doing a book signing.
And she was very angry and
she was very aggressive.
And she told me, "Why
did you have to go
and tell these things
about us in France?"
Because the image of Mauritians that
I did in my book didn't fit at all
with the postcard image
that we have.
We're a tropical country,
very touristic country.
We like being told we're the
best, we're the number one,
[inaudible] for the great.
And we don't like anything
going against that image.
And we contemporary writers
are not writing the postcard.
I don't mean to say we're
writing against the postcard
but what we're telling doesn't quite
go across with the official image.
And so I told this lady, "Well,
I'm not here to do the
promotion of Mauritius.
[Inaudible] all that at the tourist
office and they do a very good job.
And that's not my job as a writer."
But I think we're very much a
culture of representation and that's
about [inaudible] our colonial
past as to our touristic present
where we don't like things to
go against the official image.
And that's where we writers
are a bit not going [inaudible]
but that's the way it is.
>> Eve Ferguson: Do you have
a favorite Mauritian writer,
other than yourself?
[Laughs].
>> Shenaz Patel: [Laughs].
Nathacha Appanah is a great writer.
I encourage all of
you to read her books.
She has a book that
has been translated
in English that's called
"The Last Brother".
And it tells the story
of her, you know,
at one time when the Jews
were leaving Europe to go
to Palestine during
the Second World War,
a boat was anchored by the British.
And some of the, there were
1,000, a little over 1,000 Jews
that they sent to Mauritius.
And so this book tells the encounter
between the young Mauritian boy
who has lost his brothers in
[inaudible] and a young Jewish boy
who is imprisoned in Mauritius
and it's a beautiful book
and it's called "The Last Brother."
There's also [inaudible]
which is a powerful writer.
[Inaudible].
He wrote a book, a beautiful book
called [Foreign language spoken].
It's called in English it's "The
House that Walked to [inaudible]".
And it tells a lot about the inter
ethnic relationships in Mauritius
and it's really a very
interesting and beautiful book.
>> Eve Ferguson: I believe I
met [Inaudible] when she was
at the Penn Faulkner Africa
celebration last year in New York.
>> Shenaz Patel: She's a
very, very powerful writer.
>> Eve Ferguson: It would be
great if we could get her.
You know, be the second
Mauritian writer.
So tell me about your literary
journal that you founded.
Is it still published?
And why did you create a magazine?
>> Shenaz Patel: I see that you've
been doing a lot of homework.
[Laughs].
>> Eve Ferguson: Journalists.
>> Shenaz Patel: Yes.
We published, a few years back,
I was in a fit of [inaudible],
you know, people complaining,
saying, well, people don't read.
We're not a reading, we
don't have a reading culture.
If we don't buy books,
people don't read.
And always I'm sitting there
whining and complaining and I said,
"Why don't we just do something,
try to do something about it?"
We had very few book
stores in Mauritius.
They are located only
in the five main cities.
And it's always the same people
who [inaudible] book store.
A lot of people don't
go to a book store
because they feel like
it's not for them.
Whereas I think literature
should be for everybody
because it has something to tell
in exchange with every one of us.
And [inaudible] a group of friends,
writers, we sat down and we said,
"Why don't we try to do something
and launch a literary journal?"
With contemporary writers, but the
specificity of it is that we wanted
to have it going all over the
island to all those people
who don't read the new books.
And the best way to do that,
I was working in a newspaper
so I thought the distribution
network
of the newspapers is very effective.
It goes through 800 different places
throughout Mauritius and everywhere.
And so we said, "Why don't we
just try to make that and printed
on newsprint and inserted in the
newspaper, distributed over the 800
and more [inaudible]
for Mauritians."
And it was a great experience
because I went out on the day,
the first day it went out and I
went to different places and I went
into that small shop where there
were construction workers working
on the construction site
just on the other side and
[inaudible] came in the shop
to buy a sandwich or something
[inaudible], saw the journal
on the table there and he started
flipping through it and laughing
about things that were in it
and asking themselves things
about things they read.
And that was a very
interesting thing
because I think it was
a way of [inaudible].
But that ended very quickly
because unfortunately some people
are a bit narrow minded to say.
Some of us participate in that
[inaudible] where we're working
for another newspaper which was
in a way compliment of the one
who distributed us and
so there was a fight
between those two newspapers
which was so stupid.
But then it ended that I still
think about launching that again,
about working on it again.
And one of my other dreams is also
to have [inaudible] going
throughout the island
and bringing books everywhere
to little children [inaudible].
It's still an ongoing dream.
>> Eve Ferguson: So you
have a librarian streak?
>> Shenaz Patel: Yes.
I do.
>> Eve Ferguson: That's very
interesting because I was the editor
of an inserted magazine
in a newspaper as well.
So I'm beginning to think we -- .
>> Shenaz Patel: So we have
a lot in common, don't we.
>> Eve Ferguson: Yes.
I think so.
You translated "Tintin"
books into Mauritian Creole.
Why did you choose those works and
how were they received because,
as you know, that in contemporary
times some find "Tintin"
to be controversial or
specifically racist?
>> Shenaz Patel: I'll
start answering that -- .
>> Eve Ferguson: Did
you lose the mic?
>> Shenaz Patel: I think my
mic is not working [inaudible].
Thank you.
I'll start answering that by talking
about Creole which is something
that I, is very important to me.
Creole is the local language that
was born out [inaudible] of history.
We had French [inaudible]
who brought in slaves
from different parts of Africa
to work in [inaudible] fields.
And at one point they had
to find a way to communicate
so that's how Creole emerged
from the very, very difficult,
very violent period of our history.
But it's fascinating to see
how people can create out of
that something that is
very lively and creative
which Creole language is to me.
More than 90% of people
in Mauritius speak Creole
but for a long it has been
considered as another language,
as [inaudible] has been looked
down, has been really entreated
which shouldn't be because it's
the mother tongue of most of us.
But we have those prestige
languages like French and English
which people think is so important.
And there's always a kind of quarrel
between one language and the other
which shouldn't be when you
can have different languages
and international languages
and [inaudible] languages also.
The result of that is that
we have [inaudible] growing
up in the Creole language and
then at five going to school
and we're taught everything in a
language which was totally foreign
to them which is English.
So we went to school and it
was all history and mathematics
and everything in English
which amounts to here children
in America going to school and being
taught everything, I don't know,
Portuguese or something like that.
The result of that for a long
time 50% of our children were left
out school at the end of the
family cycles or around ten,
they were thrown out of school.
And it's a terrible
thing for our country.
But for a long time it was
correct to do it in a way
because there were very
labor intensive [inaudible]
with the sugarcane plantations.
But now this has changed and we
need more people who are educated.
And so there's a big fight
for Creole to be recognized
as a language and going
to our schools.
And I think that we, as writers,
have a great responsibility
to [inaudible] that fight.
It was important for us to
translate it, though I had a friend
who translated all of Shakespeare's
plays in Creole as a way
of showing that Creole [inaudible].
It's as valid as a language
as English or French.
We translated a lot.
We created a lot of Creole.
And the result is that nowadays
or as of two years ago Creole has
been introduced in our schools
and I think that's a very
great step for our country
and for the children of our country.
So translating "Tintin",
I translated, for example,
Beckett's "Waiting for Godot"
in Creole which is such a lot
of complexity even its
original language, it was like,
one time I was like taking my
hair out and why did you have
to go into such a [inaudible]?
It was very difficult.
It was really a challenge.
Translating "Tintin"
[inaudible] because
"Tintin" is a very famous comic
that was created in Belgium by Herge
and has been translated in
over more than 100 languages.
And it's very [inaudible] countries.
And translating it
in Creole was a way
of making other language exist
beside all those great languages.
[Inaudible], yes, "Tintin" is
controversial in some ways,
for example, "Tintin" or in
Congo it is said to be racist.
And some people have tried
to have it interdicted
and I'm totally against that.
I think it goes against my
freedom of knowing [inaudible]
because it tells about a period
of time and how people reacted
and formed at that period.
Herge is a product of his time
and in a way he was reacting
and creating in conformity
with that period.
He was, and at that
time [inaudible].
He wrote a book, another comic,
about men walking on the moon.
So all those refer what was in
people's minds and a certain section
of people's mind at that time.
And for me that's interesting.
I think I have a right to know that.
It helps me understand in the same
way as I'm trying to understand
at the moment what is going
on, the minds and hearts all
over the world [inaudible].
And I wouldn't like to be, some
things to be taken out or off
by people who decide for me
what I have a right to read,
and learn, and have access to.
And I think reading "Tintin" is
interesting to get in contact
with what certain people
were thinking at that time
about their prejudices,
about all of that.
So it's also interesting to me.
And I don't believe in
censorship in that way
because I think it would deprive
me of the right to take [inaudible]
and then make my own
opinion and decision.
>> Eve Ferguson: Well,
I hope that at the end
of September you were able to
celebrate Banned Books Week
in which you take every book
that's ever been maligned
and you publicize it and celebrate.
And everything that's considered
bad about it becomes good.
But I'd like you to
translate [Inaudible].
>> Shenaz Patel: I will.
I hope so, yes.
>> Eve Ferguson: Yeah.
Sounds like that -- .
>> Shenaz Patel: Again.
>> Eve Ferguson: It went out again?
Oh, okay. All right.
So let me ask my questions
and [inaudible].
>> Shenaz Patel: [Inaudible].
>> Eve Ferguson: Let me ask my
question and I'll pass it on to you.
This is the last question.
How do you see the future for
Africa and African diaspora writers?
And what steps need to be
taken to broaden the readership
of African literature in
the international community?
>> Shenaz Patel: Hmm.
This is a big question.
I think we have a problem
first with our own image
and I think we don't fit in
the [inaudible] ourselves
and what we create most of the time
because we feel like it must come
from America or even or France and
things like that to be interesting.
One of the big challenges
I think will be
to create publishing
houses throughout Africa
that would have a great network
of distribution [inaudible].
Because even between African
countries we don't get
to read our own books.
We don't get South African books
in Mauritius unless they go
through a publishing house
in New York or elsewhere.
And I think that's where
we must try the same way
as we created a [inaudible],
to take things in our own hands
and stop waiting for international
publishers to become interested
in what we are writing
and what we are doing.
So that's the future
that I think we have.
An interesting time ahead
of us to really try to put
to the word what we are
writing, what we are creating,
our very own voices and not
try to please a publisher based
in New York, or England, or in
France who's going to tell us,
"Well, you have to write along
these lines or along this current
to be able to sell,"
because I think our voices
and our stories have their own way
of saying things, have their own way
and their own [inaudible].
And we were having this ongoing
discussion about what is universal
or not and I think that's a
strange way of putting things,
that we should, when writing,
thinking how universal am I being?
Steinbeck worked all his life from
his small comfy village and he's
so universal because when you
speak about the human being
in a way you're universal anyway.
So we shouldn't be afraid
to be telling stories coming
from our countries [inaudible]
very old voices which might defer
from the international
trends of the moment.
But to be able to do that we
have to give ourselves the means
of being published
and being distributed
and that's a great challenge.
And I think that at a political
level should be [inaudible].
And because the cultural aspect
most of the times left out.
And we should call our politicians
and [inaudible] people to account
on that aspect also because it's,
as much as [inaudible] creative is
such an important part
of who we are.
>> Eve Ferguson: Before I
open it up I just wanted
to make a very small aside that
might be something that came
from another dimension but
today, had my father lived,
he would have been 93 years old.
C. Clyde Ferguson, Jr., he was the
first Black ambassador to Uganda
and it was from Uganda that
I traveled to Mauritius.
And so somehow I feel like
somehow he probably said, "Hey,
on my birthday I'm going to get you
all together because you have a lot
in common, more than just
sharing the microphone."
At this point I would like to
open up to the audience, I,
I'm going to let Anya figure out
how to do that, for questions.
And, of course, I want to
say thank you to Shenaz
for what was just an incredibly
informative conversation.
>> Shenaz Patel: Thanks to you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: So we'll
open it up for questions.
I'll come to you with the mic
and then bring the
mic back to Shenaz so.
We'll be patient with our mics.
One. Just takes one.
>> I'm curious.
You used the expression
that [inaudible] it's more there's
more freedom for you in [inaudible]
than there is and I just wondered.
What does that do when you write?
I know you just started
writing in English.
Does your writing change?
What about the writing process
changes for you when you write
in English as opposed to French?
>> Shenaz Patel: [Inaudible]
if I'm writing in English,
it's too early to say I think.
One thing I've noticed since I'm
here is I was very self conscious
at first about talking in English
because, about speaking English
because I'm not used
to speaking in English.
I speak French and Creole and
my English is kind of rusty.
And I said I felt like this
culture from [inaudible]
which is called a woman
withdraws and I feel
like that when I speak English.
I feel like I'm talking to someone
and at the same time I'm looking
for a word and I'm opening all
the drawers frantically trying
to find the right word.
It's not coming out at that moment
so I have to find another way
around to try to say things and
very frustrating because you feel
like you're not getting across
exactly what you want to say.
And you sometimes feel like
[inaudible] seems stupid
or not accurate, what
you want to say.
It's kind of negotiation all the
time and what you want to say
and how it gets across on the spot.
Writing is easier because then
you have time to go and look
for the word which you
don't have in conversation.
But it's also leading
to why I write I think
because you realize I'm not very,
people have that habit sometimes
of being to interact and kind
of ping pong the conversation
and very often I find myself like
five minutes afterward I'll say,
"Oh, that's what I wanted to say,"
but then [inaudible] the
person and say, "Come back.
That's what I wanted to say to you."
[Inaudible] you can so that's nice.
What I found here is that
Anglophone people are not that,
what I say that?
They don't hold you to account to
the purity of the language in a way
as much as French people do.
The French when you don't
speak French correctly is,
you feel much more awkward
about it because there's, well,
there's an academy which
sets the standards.
And people are very, are much
more precise about it and whereas
in English I feel like there are
so many Englishes and you are
so much more free with it.
When I read the book, and
we're talking about it now,
and Pria here is from South
Africa, we are waiting very excited
for Arundhati Roy's next
book which is due next year.
When I read "The God
of Small Things",
which is this wonderful book,
it was such a revelation to me
that you could write English that
way because just these English words
and she completes them or turns
them into Indian way of speaking
and she just use so free with that.
In French literature you have
a writer called [Inaudible]
who wrote a book, is
from Martinique I think,
who wrote a book called [Inaudible]
and he got the [inaudible]
and people were exclaiming
about how he was enriching
French language and being kind
of bringing Creole structures
and Creole words into French
and it was like a [inaudible].
In English it's done all the time.
So I feel like there's
much more freedom there.
And writing literature for me is so
much about creating language also
because we're so often
confronted with
even when we're writing now
in own language with the,
how words are inadequate
sometimes, how the words we have,
the words that exist, the words that
we haven't had, are not sufficient,
are not adequate enough to
tell what we want to tell.
And so we feel like
creating new words or trying
to find other ways of
telling the stories.
And at the moment I really feel
like in English there's more space
for that so I have
to reflect on that
and see what I'm going
to do afterwards.
Am I going to claim that freedom
in English or trying to [inaudible]
in French because, well, writing,
it depends the objective
of your writing.
If you write for yourself,
my boys are full of things
that I know I'd never
send to a publisher
because it won't get published.
It's nothing current of the moment
or [inaudible] but then [inaudible]
if you want to be published your
publisher is going to tell you,
"Well, that's not in
the trend of things,"
or what do you change,
what do you not accept.
It's very not easy.
But I feel, I really feel
like Anglophone [inaudible] there's
much more vitality at the moment.
>> Thank you very much.
And that was a wonderful,
wonderful presentation
and I loved your reading as well.
I wanted to ask you, and perhaps
in a way you suggested it,
are there particular themes,
especially, and it's a bit
of a follow-up to what you just
said, are there particular themes
that you would like to write about
that you may have already written
about or that you're
hesitant to write about?
But are there certain things
in your writing that you would
like as you're looking into
the future to write about?
>> Shenaz Patel: I usually say
that I don't write about themes.
I don't think I'm a
writer with messages.
I write a story.
Very often it starts
with a sentence.
I'll have a sentence walking
in my head for days and weeks,
and sometimes months
and I don't know why.
But it's there.
It's there for a reason [inaudible].
I know there's something that
goes through it and why do write?
Why do we sit down at one
point and come to the computer
or the blank page instead
of going out, having fun,
walking, swimming, anything?
It's because I think at
one point we feel an urge
that is very deep to tell something.
Why? I'm not quite sure.
And I'm not quite sure
I want to know.
I think [inaudible] I'm
afraid of knowing too much
and losing the ability to
write [inaudible] looks
like this one's [inaudible].
I'll speak up.
It's just that it's a mystery for
me how it happens, why it happens.
[Inaudible].
>> Eve Ferguson: On the podium?
>> On the podium.
>> Eve Ferguson: That mic works.
>> Shenaz Patel: Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Shenaz Patel: It's a very -- .
[ Inaudible ]
It's a very mysterious thing
for me and I like it that way.
I don't quite know how it
happens, why it happens.
For me it's like a, I have
a very sweet tooth, also.
I like eating.
And I like comparing writing to
that cake, that multi-layered cake,
or the [foreign language spoken].
I'm referring French.
Things happen to us every day.
We walk and overhear a conversation
and someone makes a confidence
to us and we see a thing.
We hear music.
We get a feeling of something.
And all these kinds of
pies look like that,
well, at least that's for me.
And at one time it gets
quite concrete and I feel
like there's a story
there that's taking shape.
And the precise moment for
me that it becomes writing
because I write it out of my head.
I walk around and I
write stories in my head.
And there's one particular point
when I'm reading and I feel like,
you know, on a TV screen when
there's something interfering
with image, I feel
exactly like that.
I'm reading and I have
the characters in my head
who are talking to the
characters in the book.
And it's like, and I say, "No.
No. You stop.
You put the book down.
You write what you have to write."
But it's a very, very
mysterious process.
I don't wake up one
morning and say, "Okay.
Today I'm going to write a
novel about abused women,
or violence against children,
or things like that."
But it's there, it's in the writing.
And it's in all that I live.
It's in all that makes me react.
It's in all my fears.
It's in all my doubts.
I think I write a lot with,
because I'm not satisfied
with the world that it is.
I write a lot with
what I don't understand
and that's the only thing I know.
>> Eve Ferguson: And I believe
since the mics have died
that perhaps this concludes
our program.
[Laughs]. I did just want to
say that in kind of dovetailing
on what you'd said, I saw a tee
shirt about two days ago that said,
"English is difficult
but it can be understood
through thorough thought
though," which is a little bit
of alliteration there, you know,
with the same letters
and, you know, so English.
As a former English
professor, it is difficult
but it does have many
nuances and facets.
And French, well, when you speak to
French people who don't do it right,
they don't understand you.
>> Shenaz Patel: [Laughs].
That's true.
>> Eve Ferguson: But if
there are no more questions,
can we once again thank Shenaz Patel
for her presentation
and her presence here.
And invite you to come back November
eighteenth for the Ghanaian writer,
Kwame Dawes, who will
be in conversation
with the area specialist,
Angel Batiste.
We hope you will return.
We may have December
surprise, maybe.
But I want to thank you
for coming this afternoon
and encourage you read
more African literature.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.